les aînés à faible revenu devrait
recevoir de l'aide plus tôt que prévu
plus de 200000 aînés ont perdu leur
supplément de revenu garanti en tout ou
en partie parce qu'ils ont touché une
prestation d'urgence pendant la pandémie
alors dans la mise à jour de décembre
ottawa avait prévu 742 millions pour
compenser ces pertes les paiements
seront faits à la mi avril et pour
certaines personnes en situation
précaire on annonce que le paiement sera
même fait en mars
maintenant avec l'espérance de vie qui
s'allonge devrait-on rehausser l'âge
limite de conversion des reér enfer 75
ans c'est la proposition que fait le
chercheur le que godbout dans le cadre
d'une note de recherche de l'institut
signal adressé à la ministre fédérale
des finances krischer frieden luc
godbout est avec nous ce soir bonsoir
bonsoir d'abord luc établissons les
choses les faits le reér a été créé il y
à quoi à peu près 65 ans comment ça
c'est fait donc leurs erreurs été créée
effectivement 1957 il a 65 ans donc il
arrive lui même à la retraite leur
erreur et on peut souligner que dès le
départ en 1957 on avait déjà prévu un
garde-fou en disant rendu à 71 ans c'est
l'âge limite où vous devez convertir
votre argent en une rente parce qu'on
voulait pas présent laissent accumulé
des hommes jusqu'à trop trop tard
jusqu'au décès par exemple en
1978 le ministre des finances jean
chrétien a dit ban au lieu que ce soit
obligé d'être convertie dans une rente
vous allez pouvoir de convertir le
transférer dans un ferr donc un fonds
enregistré de revenu de retraite encore
une fois l'âge limite pour le faire
c'était 71 ans au quai paul martin est
arrivé lé contexte budgétaire difficile
comme ministre des finances 1996 il dit
qu' il ramène de 71 à 69 ans est
finalement jim flaherty en 2007 a ramené
l'âge de conversion à 71 ans si bien que
65 ans plus tard on est toujours obligé
de convertir au plus tard à 71 ans avec
une espérance de vie ce le dit 65 ans
plus tard qu'il ya quand même pas mal
augmenté tu as quand même pas mal
augmenté effectivement au moment de la
création du durée dans les années 50
sites là l'espérance de vie de quelqu'un
qui avait 65 ans étaient 14 ans et demi
mouawad a aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie
de quelqu'un que 65 ans et presque 21
ans donc l'espérance de vie une fois
arrivés à la retraite et allonger de
plus de 6 ans mais on n'a pas changé le
moment où on peut convertir notre erreur
en faire donc il ya peut-être des
opportunités maintenant pour optimiser
le tout et avant de parler de cette
opportunité il faut dire le good book la
prestation de sécurité de la vieillesse
des bénéficiaires de 75 ans et plus sera
bonifié cette année donc oui c'est ce
qui m'a amené à penser au fameux 75 ans
puisque le gouvernement vient déjà de
faire une règle pour les 75 ans et plus
en bonifiant dès juillet prochain la
pension de sécurité de la vieillesse on
s'est dit pourquoi pas faire d'autres
choses à 75 emplois de 75 ans
deviendrait pas un âge charnière pour
d'autres d'autres idées donc de
permettre le report de la date limite
pour convertir son frère en faire à 75
ans est aussi il ya déjà la pensée haute
sécurité de la vieillesse on peut ne pas
la demande à 65 ans on peut leur
rapporter jusqu'à 70 mais pourquoi ne
pas la reporter jusqu'à 75 même chose
pour le régime de pensions du canada
même chose pour le régime des rentes du
québec c'est d'offrir de la souplesse
accrue je note ici le jeu contre 1,10
que les gens doivent travailler jusqu'à
75 ans jean train dès que les gens
peuvent reporter le moment où ils
demandent leur prestation ou qui
convertissent le régime qui prennent
leur retraite au moment où il le
souhaite mais ok juste pour être très
clair la pension de la sécurité de la
vieillesse resterai à 65 ans oui mais
avec la possibilité d'attendre jusqu'à
75 ans pour une pension bonifiés c'est
ça donc et même chose pour le régime des
rentes ou le régime de pensions du
canada c'est déjà possible de les
demander
jusqu'à 70 ans ont dit ce qu'ils veulent
attendre encore plus pour avoir une
prestation bonifié pourrait le faire
jusqu'à 75 ans et qui ont une fois c'est
pour offrir de la souplesse c'est dans
un contexte de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
donc ceux qui veulent repousser le
moment où ils demandent leur prestation
parce qu'ils veulent continuer de
travailler un petit peu même à temps
partiel donc ça comble des besoins
côté du marché du travail et à optimiser
le fonctionnement des régimes de
retraite et ce serait quoi le gain des
personnes d'attendre jusqu'à 75 ans pour
convertir leur reer en ferr le gain
cessé de encore une fois c'est d'offrir
de la souplesse et ceux qui veulent
continuer de travailler ils n'ont pas
besoin de ces revenus là donc qui a pas
besoin d'avoir des retraits qui débute
de 71 ans et de pouvoir les avoir des
retraits plus élevé plus tard encore une
fois comme comme la rente bonifiés pour
la passion de sécurité de la vieillesse
c'est pour ceux qui le désirent encore
une fois dit lorsqu'on tente de modifier
la pension de sécurité de la vieillesse
ou de bonifier le régime des rentes
quand on attend lui demander plus tard
lost au contraire les gens pourraient de
retirer leurs airs plus tôt encore une
fois c'est de la souplesse qu'on apprend
les régimes de retraite alors ça c'est
la proposition madame frieden vous avez
aussi publier un mémoire sur les
consultations prébudgétaires la semaine
dernière pour le québec où vous avez
parlé aussi de changements au régime des
rentes du québec
quels sont les principaux changements
que vous proposez
principal changement c on dit toujours
que le régime des rentes du québec et le
frère jumeau du régime de pensions du
canada or dans le régime de pension d'un
régime des rentes du québec si on
continue de travailler par ses 75 ans
est passé 65 ans pardon on est obligé de
cotiser au régime des rentes du québec
alors que dans le régime canadien c'est
facultatif donc passé 65 ans dans le
régime de pensions du canada la
cotisation est facultative on peut
cotiser si on le souhaite nous on n'est
pas obligé de le faire encore une fois
c'est d'offrir plus de souplesse aux
gens on propose d'harmoniser le régime
québécois régime des rentes du québec à
son homologue canadien le régime de
pension sur la nada parfait on va
surveiller les budgets qui s'en viennent
dans un mois ou deux à suivre merci de
godbout il n'y a pas de quoi avoir froid
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d